My wife is the last person in the world
who would consider me
a foodie type of person.
She is always puzzled at why, sometimes,
I couldn't even tell the difference
between beef and pork
when shopping or eating.
So a few years ago,
when I told her that I found my calling
in food, as an impact investor,
she was shocked, and thought
I had a midlife crisis.
(Laughter)
But the impact logic
behind my midlife crisis,
or midlife epiphany,
is simple.
Given its size and reach,
there's no way the world
can achieve its climate goals
without engaging China
in a significant way.
This is why I've spent much of my career
focused on supporting
environmental entrepreneurs in China,
mainly in the industrial space,
things like energy or recycling.
But I've always wondered
about how to reach
the vast number of Chinese consumers.
I found my answer in alternative proteins,
or what we prefer to call new proteins
nowadays in China.
New proteins can be plant-based,
microbial, or cell-based alternatives
to resource-intensive,
environmentally challenging
animal proteins.
Let's look at some numbers quickly.
China consumes 26 percent
of the world's meat
and 45 percent of the world's seafood.
It's also worth mentioning
that China accounts for 43 percent
of the world's pork consumption,
in the meat category.
This number is massive.
But if you look per person,
meat consumption in China is still low,
about half, compared to the US.
For milk, consumption per person
is less than half, in comparison.
And driven by rising incomes and demand,
these figures can only go up.
Meantime,
global investments in innovative foods,
with new proteins as the majority,
were over 10 billion dollars,
from 2020 to 2022.
But China had only 3.5 percent
of the total, at 362 million dollars.
I realized that investing in new proteins
should be China's answer.
Chinese consumers can be a part
of the country's environmental solution,
and by extension,
part of the global solution
to tackle climate change.
Without a doubt,
it is a huge business opportunity
in the long run as well.
But how exactly do we get people in China
to embrace new proteins,
as has happened
in other parts of the world?
Growing up in China,
I always see food
as an integral part of my culture.
On all occasions, big or small,
there's some banquet.
Like when babies are born,
loved ones pass away,
friends getting together
to bid farewell to one another.
And we always need
the so-called hard dishes, ying cai,
as a core part of these occasions,
meaning dishes with abundance
and varieties of meat.
Chinese people don't just enjoy eating.
Eating defines who we are
and where we stand in society.
As the Chinese saying goes,
wu rou bu huan,
meaning that there's no pleasure
in eating without meat.
Meanwhile, China has a long history
with plant-based foods,
which sounds positive for new proteins,
but is actually a challenge.
Old-generation mock-meat
products especially
have had a negative perception
with mainstream consumers.
They are seen as cheap, distasteful,
unhealthy alternatives,
and more intended to serve
religiously vegan or vegetarian consumers.
Environmental and animal-welfare
advocacy groups
have shifted consumer
mindsets in the West,
and eating plant-based meat
is considered morally positive.
But in China,
mainstream consumers aren't easily
swayed by the moral argument for now.
Chinese consumers are also highly
demanding regarding taste,
price and convenience.
China is incredibly diverse
in terms of styles of cooking
and food applications.
Basically, each province or region
has a style of cooking.
There's Beijing cuisine,
Shanghai cuisine, Hunan cuisine,
Szechuan cuisine and Cantonese
cuisine, to name a few.
And unlike Chinese restaurants in the US,
these regional cuisines
are not just different in the name,
they do taste different.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
To be successful and to have an impact,
entrepreneurs can't
just come out with a product
that swaps out neatly for meat product.
Alternative products
will need to be tasty,
affordable and regionally appropriate.
This calls for investments in innovation,
research and development.
Moreover, we need
new distribution channels,
beyond specialty stores
and vegetarian restaurants,
and they must be widespread, nationwide,
especially in China,
where online selling plays
an increasingly dominant role.
And with the young generation
mainstream consumers,
it certainly helps
to engage high-end chefs
to put new proteins on their menus.
And these new products need personality:
brands that seem hip and compelling
to younger consumers.
New proteins must also enter
the consumer consciousness
on a wholesale level,
meaning the entire industry
needs good marketing campaigns.
Entrepreneurs need to support one another
and all relevant stakeholders
to gain momentum.
All of this requires investment
and patience, of course.
The good news is that we're starting
to see some progress.
For example, look at the alternative
dairy company, Oatly.
The Oatly Tea Master,
an oat-based drink developed in China,
replacing cow's milk for milk tea,
was introduced to the Chinese
market in March 2022.
By the end of 2022,
the product had entered
over 50,000 tea stores around China,
with 20 million units sold.
Oatly's initial success in China
has resulted from its localized
product and marketing strategy,
investment in local production
and distribution-channel expansion
in collaboration with local partners.
Meanwhile, mainstream Chinese consumers
have been drinking
all flavors of plant-based milk
because of the past lack
of cow milk products.
I believe plant-based drinks
are low-hanging fruit
for introducing new proteins
and having impact in China more quickly
and in a more capital-efficient way.
Dao Foods, the investment
firm I cofounded,
has invested in about 20 new protein
companies in China and for China.
Products from Starfield, Xing Qi Ling,
such as their plant-based tuna,
beef and chicken,
are showing up at restaurant chains
and store shelves across China.
Its clients include Sam's Club,
KFC, FamilyMart
and China's equivalent of Starbucks,
Luckin Coffee, to name a few.
Plant Now!, Zhi Wu Jia Dao,
a plant-based milk tea venture,
has recently entered more than 500
local convenience stores in Qingdao,
a new tier-one city on China's east coast,
and is ready to enter another 1,000 stores
in China's Anhui province
with their coconut milk tea product.
These young generation entrepreneurs
are trying to develop products
that appeal to mainstream consumers
in every way.
Equally important,
they are helping overcome the negative
perception of plant-based products
with a new look and feel
and working with the right
distribution partners.
Aside from entrepreneurial efforts,
the new protein sector in China
is also gaining momentum
on a few other fronts.
Over the past few years,
we've hosted eight
boot camps across China,
bringing together and inspiring
hundreds of entrepreneurs
who spend time learning from their peers
and figuring out
how to better their technology,
improve marketing, expand distribution
and raise more money.
Chinese President Xi Jinping
made some food-related remarks last year,
encouraging the seeking of new proteins
from plants and microbes.
Local government
is getting involved as well.
One municipal government
in China's Yangtze Delta region
agreed to jointly develop a new protein
entrepreneurship program with us,
offering office space,
potential funding and more.
I would love to see
mainstream Chinese consumers
massively adopt new proteins,
making them a part of their daily diet.
I don't expect consumers to give up
on animal products entirely,
but having more protein
diversification and choices
will allow them to weigh factors
like the environment and climate impact,
to make more balanced
and informed food decisions.
Given China's rising demand
for quality proteins
and the climate ramifications,
climate-friendly investors worldwide
should be all over new proteins in China.
But they are not.
Many international investors
continue to shy away from China.
Maybe geopolitics is the problem.
Perhaps they aren't sure
if they will be able to get their money
out of China if they need to.
Or it could be the flawed assumption
that China's problems are so unique
that it requires solutions
led by Chinese people alone.
But whether you're an investor,
and entrepreneur or a consumer,
if you want to be a hero
and game-changer in this space,
show me the money!
(Laughter)
Even if it's just one meal at a time,
one product at a time
or one investment at a time.
China is indispensable in addressing
global climate changes,
and we should work collectively
to make China part of the global solution.
Let's all strive beyond,
do the impossible,
always look at the upside
and keep exploring the way,
AKA the "dao," to get there.
For the one and only planet
we share and call home,
we must do it, we can do it,
and we will.
Thanks, everybody.
(Applause)